cientos de rusos en las estaciones de
esquí de Bulgaria se hacen una pregunta
cómo volverán a casa tras la decisión de
la Unión Europea de cerrar el espacio
aéreo a todos los aviones rusos por la
invasión a Ucrania las opciones son
pocas
llegamos hace tres días a Bank y ahora
los cielos están cerrados y no podemos
volver esto es muy triste y estamos muy
disgustados estamos muy preocupados por
lo que está pasando no solidarizamos con
toda la gente
una situación similar a la de los rusos
que están de vacaciones en países
caribeños como Cuba la asociación rusa
de operadores turísticos Calcula que
cerca de 18.000 turistas rusos están
atrapados en la región
la guerra es otra cosa la guerra es
dolor lloramos nuestros amigos e hijos
sufren no queremos la guerra queremos La
Paz
Y es que los civiles rusos están pagando
el precio de la decisión de su
mandatario además de las sanciones en
contra de su país los discursos
xenófobos contra los rusos han aumentado
con especulaciones incluso sobre la
expulsión de rusos de universidades en
todo el mundo
hay varios rumores de que las
universidades europeas han estado
expulsando a estudiantes rusos desde la
agresión a Ucrania como afirma la
asociación de universidades francesas es
falso y la eua no ha recibido ningún
informe de posibles expulsiones por
parte de ninguno de sus miembros los
expertos avisan que la población rusa
también está sufriendo las consecuencias
de la guerra con amigos y familiares en
el frente incertidumbre e inestabilidad
económica en el país